all right Sharina yes Serena would you
grow up where are you from originally
um I'm from Azusa California a Souza yes
and tell me about your family growing up
you had Mom and Dad
um I grew up with my mom and dad
um
they got divorced pretty early when I
was like in third grade
my dad
sold the drug sold our house for drugs
um without telling us so
um we had to move to La Verne
um
I guess he blew the money pretty fast so
he asked my mom to move back in with her
um
so she let him we're living in a single
wide trailer in Laverne for
for a few years
and then she met the neighbor from his
son married him
and he pretty much took care of us
my dad was living with us at the time
too your Mom married the next door
neighbor yes she did but your dad was
still living with you guys yeah because
he was on drugs he couldn't take care of
himself
and um how would you describe your
childhood in general General
um
my mom she's kind of bipolar my dad was
never there
you know due to drugs
um
it's really lonely you know just
how far are you in school I um
made it to ninth grade and I got
pregnant 14.
I'm at my high school sweetheart Matthew
and we decided to have a kid pretty
early because I didn't have a family
that'd be a good idea you know
until you raise your child at 14. yeah I
um we had Jude 14.
it was more of a grade school sweetheart
wasn't it 14 14. no that's the beginning
of high school okay ninth grade
ninth grade
go pregnant 14 had a mess
15. oh I see okay yeah that's high
school yeah you uh you raised the child
um I raised a child for most
of
well okay
he got taken away when he was two
so
then we fought to get him back we're
going back why did you lose we lost it
when he was two
because due to fighting there's a lot of
domestic violence going on
because Matthew started shooting up meth
and um
he was just when he would shoot meth he
would become a monster you know
he would just
sure
accusing me of things I didn't do
cheating on him doing
[Music]
just do things you know and you can
start beating me and
I guess the neighbors are called the
cops once and
CPS came to chewed away
but he said the family fought for Jude
and they got him back
and then a little later we had um
we had Dylan
Dylan's 13 right now so
you have one child uh no I have three
three yeah where are they now they're
with his parents
yeah
um
we were together for 17 years
and then
after 17 years he took a break
because he couldn't do drugs anymore he
didn't want to do drugs anymore and I
was stuck on drugs
and um
after the break after a couple years
no I don't know who it was it well after
maybe a year break he came back to me
and
he was really adamant about getting
married
um
I was already in a relationship but I
said okay you know because he was in
jail the guy I was with
and um
so we go down to the
people who doesn't Norwalk to get the
paper signed
we got the license but the next day was
the ceremony December 13th
and
on our way to the ceremony he had to use
restroom we stopped our food for less
and I told him I couldn't do it because
I got a cold feet and I didn't want to
go back to
him beating me again and all that stuff
you know I can free of him
so I told him I couldn't do it and um he
went to the
um was it the trash compact room and
suffocating himself with the electrical
cord
and ever since then I've been
out here I mean I came to La that day
um I see him in the hospital I said
goodbye
I just dropped everything I stopped
talking to my kids stop talking to my
family since he committed suicide even
on the streets yes
I just let go of everything I mean
he was my life you know
how long you've been on the streets now
probably he died
um
2013.
so since then seven years ten like nine
or ten years yeah
you uh
you live where now where do you stay
um
is it on the streets of MacArthur Park
um
I was doing with
well I met a dealer out there
um I'm not gonna name his name
but I was staying with him for a while
and
things got pretty crazy there I mean I
couldn't really handle the
um
that kind of life you know it's the
paranoia and
and the constant people back and forth
and selling and all that stuff I
couldn't handle that so I just left his
house and went back on the streets
what is what is your drug now it's
fennel and um speed and Xanax
[Music]
I've Progressive fennel um
I guess when it came out to MacArthur
Park because I was only addicted to
Norcos and
I would try heroin once in a while but
when Matt died you know I came out here
I couldn't find them
and fennel seemed to be a lot cheaper
a lot more available it's everywhere
how do you support yourself now
um my Boost I go to stores I steal
yeah
the supermarket is stolen oh yeah yeah
there's um
there's vendors everywhere
they have orders they give you you know
um
the Ross vendors will tell you what they
need and you'll go steal it yeah exactly
like a lot of name brand stuff
like coffee a lot of like Tide Pods
whatever I guess
people use every day too you know
that's how I support my habit
but I mean recently I have
I mean I'm getting tired of this life
you know so I'm trying to get off of the
streets
I'm trying to get housing and stuff and
um
hopefully go to rehab soon
what emotions do you go through living
this life any emotions
um you see I started this drug to forget
about that day
that there haven't you know every since
it's not my fault but you know
yeah but
it's like um
now that he's got anything about him
even more I know that I'm on the journey
thinking about it anymore and it doesn't
I don't know
it's just like is he using as well he
wasn't using um
any opiates it was just meth he was just
let me meth
[Music]
but like now he's a part of my life more
than ever you know
and I can't stop thinking about him like
no matter how numb I am he's just
constantly on my mind
my kids don't have a father because
my choices I knew if I if I decided to
marry him you know
he wouldn't have done it because what he
wanted to do was get sober
and um try to start again you know and I
wasn't ready for that that's why I had
to put my cold feet
do you have any friends here
I have coincidence I mean I don't really
call any friends
there's a few people I like confined and
you know
once in a while
have you tried to quit
um
I tried
um a couple times I can't get past day
two
just because it's pretty painful
physically
and then emotionally too
foreign
what's your biggest fear now
these fear
was that I'll be stuck on the streets
forever
I'll be stuck on fentanyl I'll die like
this and then we'll be able to say sorry
to my children
[Music]
I have three beautiful boys I just
neglected
and they need me the most you know
I'll bring you with your parents
is what kind of LED you down this path
um
I don't want to blame anything on
anybody else but
I'm sure if my life is a little bit
different you know like
I'd submitted influences I'm sure
things have been different you know
my dad was a great like friend but he
wasn't
too good of a dad you know my mom the
same thing
um I first started smoking with my dad
you know smoking meth
at what age
um
what was I was 13. 13.
[Music]
and then um whenever I would go back
home to
um if I was sick my dad would give me
heroin from the clinic
and he make sure I was well but he would
do it in a loving way you know I guess
because they never wanted to see me sick
you know
tell me what it's like living on the
streets as a female
[Music]
um
it's very difficult it's um
scary
um the ratio from guys to girls is is
I mean real numbered you know like
there's
probably like five girls on the streets
you know and the rest are guys
so and they're they're all
they're always trying to like um get me
to smoke with them or like trying to get
me to do like sexual Deeds you know for
money or for drugs but
is the Relentless too that's another
thing is a relentless
and there's like years a lot of stories
about rape and this and that you know I
know I know a few girls with a few
acquaintances of mine who got raped you
know or like kidnapped and
like stuck somewhere
it's been your worst experience
since you've been
living like this
living like this
[Music]
um
probably
I've known a couple people who died just
orders have been all
probably losing them too and have you
already yeah
I would eat too
um I would I was in jail for three days
and I got out kind of clean I guess and
went right back to smoking Fentanyl and
the first hit I took I I went out
and
I remember just waking up and all I'm
like
12 cops around me and paramedics around
me I couldn't remember what happened you
know until like a minute later
and I remembered what happens
fennel
but I try to quit that's when I tried to
quit was after that day because I almost
died you know
and um
I just couldn't
we couldn't after the third day it was
too painful like I said
what do you think most people don't
understand about
fentanyl addiction
um or any drug addiction but fentanyl
seems to be particularly tough
I think okay I think when
our parents are trying to use tough love
and push us right ostracizes
I think it makes it a lot worse you know
because that they're taking away our
only connections you know
and they're putting us out there on the
streets and
where it's readily available and
and then that's the worst thing is they
can do this is somebody is just not be
there for them you know
it's not understanding it I guess
because once like you're introduced to
it and you
you take a hit and you're you're pretty
much pretty much like
you're stuck you know from that point on
even if you don't like the feeling you
know you're just it hurts to get off of
it yeah is that really what it's about
now for you is it's just trying to avoid
the
the misery of not having it yeah it's
basically just being normal now like
because when you're on it you're not
particularly
I'm not I mean I don't like I don't like
the knot I don't like the tiredness you
know but if I don't if I don't smoke it
I I feel like crap I feel like I have
like a really bad cold
or like I'll start vomiting you know
it's just it's horrible
so like
yeah that's why I'm still on it
what do you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of this
let me personalize them I would say um
don't take anybody for granted
basically you never know when to lose
them
you know
life is fragile and
very special and you can you lose to me
any moment you know
so whether they're on drugs or not just
be there for them I guess
all right Serena thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome I wish
you lots of luck out here thank you
thank you